ciudad de méxico- retiró la estatua de
cristóbal colón' de una de sus
principales avenidas para evitar que
fuera derribada por los manifestantes
que se esperan para este 12 de octubre
méxico ha sido uno de los países más
críticos con el pasado colonial español
no está de acuerdo en tener este tipo de
monumentos en la calle porque pienso que
representan represión o también un tipo
de represión que hubo en esa época
entonces para mí debería de haber otro
tipo de monumentos que incentiven otro
tipo de pensamiento que temer a estas
personas en un monumento como tipo
idolatrando las el mensaje contra el
colonialismo empezó con un llamado del
propio presidente hace poco más de un
año que este fin de semana repitió
porque todavía
aunque se niegue
hay heridas abiertas
y es mejor reconocer
hubieron abusos y que se cometieron
errores
es mejor
pedir perdón heridas que también
denuncian en colombia donde tumbaron una
estatua del explorador español sebastián
de belalcázar pero las reivindicaciones
también han cargado contra otros
antiguos imperios como el británico o el
francés durante las protestas del
movimiento lives matter la estatua de
cristóbal colón entre otros personajes
de la época fue retirada y barbados un
país independiente que sigue teniendo
como jefa de estado a la monarca isabel
2a anunció su intención de romper con su
jefatura
habiendo alcanzado la independencia hace
más de medio siglo en nuestro país no
puede tener dudas sobre su capacidad de
autogobierno sus gobernantes ha llegado
el momento de dejar atrás nuestro pasado
colonial colonial dijo
el movimiento de revisión histórica en
las américas es cada vez más potente y
en él se tiene la intención de
vislumbrar las atrocidades cometidas
durante los siglos de dominación de las
potencias coloniales